all right now a Breaking News Hannity
exclusive surrounding the all-important
Georgia Senate race as we have obtained
the full body cam footage of Raphael
warnock's dispute with his ex-wife in
March of 2020 where she accused him of
trying to run her over with his car and
he actually ran over her foot with his
car and where his well-crying ex-wife
told police that Warnock is a great
actor and that he'd done all this and
suggested that he has a violent past as
always we'll play with play the tape
will let you decide take a look
just starts backing the car up
and he wasn't going fast like I'm not
I'm not bleeding but
I just can't believe he would run me
open so you think it was attention
I think obviously I was standing here
the door is open and I'm leaning into
the car how can you drive the car when
I'm leaning into it he knew it was a
risk and he doesn't care he just cares
about his own stuff he's got a flight to
catch and that's all that matters this
man's running for the United States
Senate and all he cares about right now
is his reputation I've tried to keep the
way that he acts under wraps for a long
time and today he crossed the line he's
like I had to draw the line today I've
had enough of him thinking he can do
whatever he wants because of who he is
and treat me any kind of way and I just
keep taking it and being quiet for his
reputation sake and I've had it
now she's making an accusation that he
was using his car as a weapon to run her
over and in fact ran over her foot in
the process as a result of this domestic
dispute it raises a question why wasn't
Raphael Warnock arrested and charged in
the incident which does in and of itself
raise a lot of ethical questions uh
because isn't it pretty much standard
operating procedure for police
departments and all around the country
when there's a domestic dispute and
there is an allegation of violence that
one person has taken and down to Police
Headquarters the one that is charged
anyway warnock's troubles don't stop
there he wants to end cash Bell he
demonized police you know or even
referred to them as Thugs and gangsters
he also said you cannot serve God and
the military he compared America's
Legacy to let's see Fidel Castro he
praised oh Louis Farrakhan and the
Reverend Jeremiah Wright he wants CRT in
our schools he supports abortion on
demand through the night ninth month no
restriction on abortion he's been a
rubber stamp for everything Biden and
the new green deal climate cult
alarmists he's hell-bent on destroying
pretty much our way of life in this
country but Warnock is just one of many
extreme socialists that are running for
office that includes the ever-struggling
Socialist to the left of Bernie Sanders
trust fund Bratton a hoodie that's never
worked a job in his life John fetterman
an NBC news reporter even noted the
fetterman struggled to speak didn't seem
to understand the conversation prior to
the interview but of course that
reporter faced pushback from left wing
host Savannah Guthrie the expert that
she is take a look
NBC News agreed to fetterman's request
to use a transcription program during
this interview because he's still
experiencing auditory processing issues
from the stroke meaning he can't always
understand what he's hearing walk me
through why we need the closed
captioning how it works yeah it's it's
really just how things happen because I
sometimes will hear things in a way
that's not perfectly clear so I use
captioning so I'm able to see what
you're saying on the in captioning and
Savannah we did find that in small talk
before the interview without captioning
it seemed it was difficult for fetterman
to understand our conversation yeah and
Tasha you had mentioned that last night
on nightly since then other journalists
who've also dealt with fetterman came
forward and said they had a different
experience
yeah and Savannah that's completely fair
that that was their experience we can
only report our own
maybe somebody can show Savannah Guthrie
the tape of fetterman saying uh kick the
balls in authority and maybe calling Joe
Biden Joe bin and by the way get this
during an interview today with the Penn
Live editorial board well board member
Jeffrey Lord a friend of this program he
asked fetterman about my open invitation
for him to join this program for the
full hour and to do my radio show if he
wants for the full three hours here's
the response
Sean Hannity said that he has repeatedly
issued an invitation to your campaign to
be his guest solo for the three hours of
his radio show and one full hour of his
National TV show he said he's got no
response from you which I assume means
you are no so my question is Sir
has the United States Senator and I work
for one that would be the late John
Hines you have to do this you know
debating the opposition thing all the
time and I was just curious as to what
your your reasoning is for not doing
that
I I just I just don't believe that I
mean it's it's actually a fact Fox News
and part of the Sean Hannity is a part
of has spent the last five or six weeks
you know unloading on us and saying out
outrageous things and going after us uh
in in a way more so than every other of
the the other Democratic uh candidates
combined so this is not seriously a fair
and serious you know venue and I just uh
would not
take that it's an unserious uh
invitation because he's all in for for
Dr Oz and that's that's the truth
all right here with reaction radio talk
show host larielle along with Al cake
founder clay Travis uh Larry let me
start with you well uh the thing that he
doesn't really want to do is answer a
question because he hasn't been asked a
lot of hard questions here in
Pennsylvania 81 billion dollar industry
he wants a moratorium on fracking he
wants absolutely no restrictions on
abortion he wants uh the taxpayers to
fund uh heroin injection sites that are
safe uh this guy has advocated for more
convicted murders to be released than
any other candidate in the history of
running for the U.S Senate he wants to
open up the prisons in Pennsylvania and
let out a third at least of the
population uh this guy is more left than
Bernie Sanders on every issue Larry no
wonder he won't come on this program or
answer anybody's questions
yeah and it's interesting Sean he says
he won't come on your program because
you're quote all in for Dr Oz for crying
out loud I ran for governor as you know
out here in California the newspapers
were all in on my opponent Gavin news
and the Sacramento Bee L.A times I still
did interviews if we Republicans don't
do interviews because the media is all
in on the other side we wouldn't do any
interviews and regarding Raphael
warnock's a videotape that's very
compelling stuff Sean but you and I both
know there is a double standard when a
female accuses a Democrat versus when a
female accuses a republican the media
has a very different attitude remember
Tara Reid
she's a woman who claimed that that Joe
Biden essentially assaulted her and
Kamala Harris even said she believed
Tara Reid now Kamala Harris Works for
Joe Biden so either she's working now
for somebody she accused of a sexual
assault or now she believes Tara Reid is
a liar and you and I both interviewed
Juanita Broderick who alleged that Bill
Clinton raped her and that two weeks
after the alleged rig Hillary Clinton
verbally intimidated her to my knowledge
Sean Hillary has never been asked about
what Juanita Broderick said so the
double standards are just all in your
face you know Clay let's go to Raphael
Warnock for a second you saw this tape
of his ex-wife alleging that he was
using his car as a weapon to run her
over and in fact ran over her foot he's
been taken to court for not paying child
support uh we also know that he
obstructed Justice he was arrested for
obstructing justice in a child abuse
investigation for a camp that he was
running and that ultimately found five
examples of child abuse now now why
isn't the media in the great state of
Georgia have been questioning Raphael
Warnock the way they've been hammering
Herschel Walker
you know when Larry knows and everybody
out there listening to us knows why
because Georgia is the firewall now Sean
what you offered to John fetterman I
would extend the offer the same way
maybe maybe he won't be able to claim
that I've been as vociferous of a Critic
of his although I'd like to think that I
have because he is the worst candidate
that either party has nominated for a
Statewide elective office in all of 2022
and that was before Sean he didn't have
the health status to be able to be a
United States senator look the job of a
senator is to articulate uh in a
convincing Manner and advocate for your
state he cannot do that he cannot speak
he has to conduct interviews using a
desktop computer screen in order to be
able to see what's being asked and Sean
if you watch that NBC interview he
wasn't even consistent in being able to
answer those questions and so if you
look at these numbers Dr Oz is going to
win in Pennsylvania and I think what's
going on and I would just say to the
people of Pennsylvania but certainly the
people of Georgia just listen to this
case do you believe that Joe Biden has
done a good job as president if you do
then you should vote for Raphael Warnock
no matter what because he is a rubber
stamp for Joe Biden if you however
believe as most Georgians do and most
pennsylvanians and most Americans do
that Joe Biden has been an awful
president then how in the world could
you vote for someone to be a rubber
stamp for him look Herschel needs to win
it's a big deal we're 27 days out the
people of Georgia have a chance to redo
the error that they made in January of
2021 when they put Raphael Warnock in
office he needs to be gone and John
Federman quite simply cannot do the job
if he had any sense of decency Sean he
would step down in his position else to
run because he doesn't have the health
ability to do this these are elections
Republicans but he's the most radical
candidate ever to run in the country and
Larry I didn't even mention he wants you
know Pennsylvania to be a sanctuary
State I didn't mention that as mayor of
Braddock Pennsylvania he chased an
innocent African-American jogger down
the street held him with a shotgun to
his face uh the guy did nothing and
nothing even happened in the town to
justify that imagine if a trump did that
or any Republican had done that
they've got two issues their issue is
abortion and their issue is by the way
these Republicans over there are
systemically racist they've got that and
that's it they can't talk about prices
they can't talk about gas prices they
can't talk about the borders they can't
talk about the pull out of Afghanistan
all they can do is pound the table about
abortion and about calling the people on
the right systemically racist that's all
they've got and come November they are
going to be toast in the house and
hopefully in the Senate I hope you're
right both of you anyway thank you both
clay appreciate it Larry as always thank
you